so when did you first realize that voice
acting was something that you liked and
could be successful at you know I had a
moment early on where I first realized
what voice actors were before I was even
in the first grade they showed on the
Walt Disney
Clarence Nash doing the voice of Donald
Duck and it just I don't know how to
process it because Donald Duck was real
and my mind somehow and to see this
distinguished man in a suit I started
thinking about who's Daffy Duck
who's Bullwinkle J moose who are all
these characters and you could go into
the record stores in those days we
didn't have Wikipedia go to the
children's section and look at the
record albums exceed dogs Butler June
Foray and all these people so yeah it
was something I aspired to very early on
but I've been very lucky in that regard
because you get to play characters you'd
never get to play on camera
and what about your process when finding
a new voice for a character for example
Chucky
did you try multiple voices you have to
read the script and see what it is that
they need of you and in this case Chucky
was like an infant
you know seeing the world for the first
time through new eyes I mean it doesn't
start out as a a psychopath in any way
and are obviously Lars clever the
director and the writers were there the
producers they held my hand every step
of the way because it's also a matter of
where you make the shift into the darker
side of him and I just saw the film for
the first time yesterday and you know
because I would give them alternates cuz
there's one point where I would say if I
can't be your best friend then no one
can I give him another take was if I
can't be here best friend
can and be very sinister and degrees you
know I did the high and the low for you
but I give you degree so they could pick
one like a jigsaw puzzle piece and it
was interested to see which one they
used to modulate the character
throughout what's gratifying two things
one people have said today that they
sympathize in a way with Chucky because
he's he's corrupted by the world he
doesn't have any intent other than to
please his best friend his best buddy
and the other was that my wife said I
forgot it was you doing the voice about
that twenty minutes in which is a real
compliment because you want to make the
character organic and not they Oh that's
Marc's voice you know I think a lot of
people on Twitter are gonna be really
disappointed they go yes Mark Hamill is
doing Chucky he's gonna do it like the
Joker well if it called for that I would
have but it didn't so I hope they're not
too disappointed make Shrek I have to
tell you Scottish is one of the most
difficult for me dialects to do and Mike
Meyers does a great job but it's donkey
in my swamp something like that porky I
don't I'm not familiar for he's new to
the Toy Story 4 ok I am NOT a Troy I was
made for soap salad maybe chilli trash
oh that's so sad he's a disposable spoon
sonic I love there was backlash over how
his teeth looked on the internet I say I
don't know fast
get too slow
[Music]
that's the best I could do oh you know
this is a true story when I was doing
the Muppet Show I went in to meet with
the writers and Jim Henson
and he gov he asked me is there anything
that you want to do like you sing or do
you do any impressions and I said oh
well you know I've been known to do
impressions and he looked at me he said
who do you do it's in the show because
he was being sincere he wasn't being
snarky
he just didn't see it coming
I lost an Annie award one time cuz I got
nominated for Joker I said who's in my
category they said Jeremy Irons for the
Lion King I said okay stop are you
kidding me one of the greatest
performances ever I believe it was just
between us you might want to work on
that little roar of yours Simba I'm not
surprised to see you alive wish I could
raise one eyebrow he was fantastic one
of my favorites okay now is the Will
Smith version of the Robin Williams
version because I can't do either your
take on it okay
[Music]
the most impressive the long contain
often imitated but never again
how does he eat a peak
[Music]
okay I gotta get on more shows like Lolo
Kitty and strawberry shortcake I for
some reason they cast me only as just
old degenerates and creepy villains I
always had certainty in here for it it
was really weird
my parents were nervous about me because
I said is that me more need for 9 year
old to be working on his Richard Nixon
impression hey mom I did let me like
this point lately where they go yes
honey that's that's good but being able
to imitate Porky Pig is not gonna get
you anywhere in life
[Music]